[Applauso]
[Musica]
Buongiorno a tutti
il corpo umano è fatto per muoversi
e
il corpo umano è fatto per muoversi e
l'evoluzione della specie ha fatto sì
che l'essere umano abbia potuto
sviluppare nel corso della storia sette
schemi motori di base che sono Non
ridete perché ci sono troppe R camminare
correre rotolare saltare afferrare e
lanciare ed arrampicarsi lo schema
motorio del scivolare cioè lo
scivolamento indipendentemente
dall'attrezzo Che utilizzeremo per farlo
è qualcosa che non è insito nella natura
umana motivo per cui quando Impariamo ad
andare in bici o quando impariamo a
sciare o anche a nuotare il movimento
rimane indelebile in quello che è il
nostro bagaglio motorio non ce lo
scordiamo più
ho iniziato a sciare quando avevo 4 anni
e anzi
vorrei dire di aver imparato
aver iniziato a gestire il
l'equilibrio sugli sci quando avevo 4
anni e Credetemi che dopo 26 anni senza
essere ancora scesa dai miei attrezzi
non sono ancora riuscita a essere la
sciatrice che vorrei essere e non sono
ancora riuscita ad avere la padronanza
dell'equilibrio che vorrei perché lo sci
è uno sport con un equilibrio altamente
precario
E alquanto instabile stare in piedi su
un paio di sci non basta perché non
assolve il tuo compito da sciatrice che
è quello di aprire il cancelletto
scendere su un tracciato obbligato con
degli attrezzi lunghi
in base alla disciplina con delle
ciancature anche diverse nel minor breve
tempo possibile
lo sci
è uno sport veramente che ti porta a
dover gestire i disequilibri
Ma è proprio lo chef la qualità dello
sciatore Bravo è quella di continuare a
sbilanciarsi nel vuoto continuare a
muoversi e a muoversi creando
disequilibrio
da questo preambolo cosa capiamo capiamo
fondamentalmente che la parola
equilibrano nell'accezione e nella sua
etimologia che è ecus libro ovvero e =
peso che è raffigurato da quella che è
la classica bilancia con i due pesi che
si contrappongono quello per me non è
equilibrio quello da espressione è
un'espressione di staticità
di bilanciamento
ma di uguaglianza
l'equilibrio dei tempi moderni come lo
intendo io è qualcosa che
che presuppone il movimento
è qualcosa che presuppone quella che
Aristotele chiamava la dinamis che è la
forza e la potenza l'energia che ci
mette un corpo verso un movimento uno
scopo un fine
lo sci
è uno sport che
richiede il vuoto
perché quando sono alla cancelletto di
partenza
il primo
quando mi manca un 30 secondi per aprire
il cancelletto tutto a posto sono lì che
mi concentro Chiudo gli occhi e cerco di
stare dentro me stessa la prima azione
che dovrò fare è quella di andare contro
il mio istinto e di buttarmi nel vuoto
fuori dalla rampa del cancelletto di
partenza così facendo imprimerò
un'accelerazione al mio corpo e da lì
cercherò di
muovermi in quello che è un
disequilibrio continuo che Ricerco per
concatenare al meglio le curve
Ci vuole coraggio a riempire i propri
vuoti e ci vuole coraggio a
imprimere l'accelerazione anche quando
sei al cancelletto di partenza
tantissime persone mi dicono sempre
Sofia abbiamo visto la tua faccia in
televisione e
ricentrata non ericentrata
er in equilibrio oppure oggi non era in
equilibrio
ed è vero perché io ho delle giornate in
cui sono centratissima posso sopperire
magari a un ginocchio che mi costringe a
fare un percorso amato disperatissimo
verso le olimpiadi del dell'anno scorso
oppure
a volte un equilibrio che mi riesce a da
quel un valore aggiunto quando mi
presento il cancelletto dopo aver subito
un'operazione chirurgica al giorno prima
con un'anestesia generale però quando la
centratura di me stessa quando io sono
in me stessa quando con me i miei
appoggi interiori non ho paura di niente
anche se a dir la verità ogni tanto
ci sono delle curve in cui sento quasi
di non farcela ma se io
se io faccio affidamento a quelle che
sono le mie capacità se io cercherò di
creare una centratura mia interiore e
trovarmi appoggi interni so benissimo
che riuscirò a risolvere il
disequilibrio della curva cercando con
forza gli appoggi sui piedi alla fine è
tutto ciò che serve un po' di stabilità
nel gesto
muoversi nel vuoto Non è semplice
Perché fa paura per certi aspetti perché
implica disordine perché caos
però se sappiamo la direzione dove del
nostro movimento se sappiamo come
muoverci
Abbiamo tutto ciò che serve sono una
sciatrice che
a differenza di tante altre non hai il
tush The Nash la classe Io scendo con
forza irruenza con un onesto un po'
particolare la mia forza è quella di
secondo me di leggere bene le pendenze
di la mia forza e l'interpretazione
delle linee e la visione su alcune
traiettorie
e questo
mi rende la sciatrice che sono ma per
farlo io ho bisogno Quando sono a quel
cancelletto di partenza di avere tutta
me stessa
e spesso mi è capitato di non essere in
equilibrio sugli sci perché alla fine lo
sci è sempre il riflesso di te stesso
del tuo carattere è il riflesso di ciò
che hai dentro e quando sei centrata
bene ma poi quando ci sono giornate
invece in cui mi presento il cancelletto
e sono totalmente decentrata E allora
ancora di più ha bisogno di concentrarmi
e di trovare la centratura in me stessa
per far sì che non sia la gara non siano
le curve a dettare il mio ritmo ma sono
sempre io a dover andare verso le cose
Inoltre lo sci è uno sport che
ti porta abbastanza al limite perché
quando indipendentemente dal campo di
azione di ciascuno di noi quando
insegui la tua grandezza per provi a
inseguire la tua grandezza personale
in determinati campi
le scelte di vita che fai Sono
abbastanza estreme e ti portano a un
disequilibrio e a un caos a un disordine
attorno a te veramente importante
ma ciò che conta secondo me è veramente
proprio avere il centro di sé e sapere
con fermezza Qual è la direzione in cui
vogliamo andare e non aver paura ad
affrontarla esattamente come in una
curva da sci da una curva precedente a
dalla curva precedente alla quella
successiva c'è questo momento di vuoto
che è un momento di alleggerimento dove
il mio corpo deve veramente andare
contro istinto Eppure è proprio lì che
io trovo il mio centro spesso mi è
capitato di essere totalmente in
disequilibrio oppure sugli sci di cadere
di farmi male anzi la storia la mia
storia come sciatrice fatta di Vittoria
infortuni purtroppo
però
ho sempre cercato di trovare un
equilibrio in quello che era il mio
camminare su questa corda tesa quasi
funambolica su cui mi rottava a vivere
Perché
spendo
260 giorni all'anno in hotel con gente
che non mi sono scelta con persone
con cui mi alleno ragazze con cui mi
alleno dove però poi al cancelletto di
partenza saremo tutte acerrimi rivali la
messa appunto dagli Scille o in palestra
il riposo Io ho una routine che parte
alle 6 di mattina e finisce alle 10 di
sera arrivo veramente stremata e faccio
da settembre fino a fine marzo
tutti i giorni via e ho preventivate
circa 15 notti a casa Più o meno
e poi Più sali più Cerchi di arrivare
alla vetta
e più cose hai da gestire attorno a te
E allora Secondo me è fondamentale per
non perdersi troppo
Anzi riuscire a tenere la barra di se
stessi dritte come dice Mio padre è
importante avere con sé i propri valori
e la propria centratura
perché camminare è un salire e scendere
camminare o andare avanti camminare
anche incappare nei fallimenti che non
saranno mai grandi abbastanza da
definire noi stessi perché ciò che ci
definisce veramente Secondo me la voglia
la forza e la volontà di voler
continuare a camminare
la voglia di voler alzarsi da quelle che
sono le nostre cadute però la cosa più
importante
è mantenere secondo me il fisso il
centro di noi stessi e lo sguardo avanti
questo per me è la mia idea di
equilibrio ma l'idea di equilibrio che
ho anche è
data esattamente come in una curva in
quel momento dove ho dove devo perdere
l'equilibrio dove devo creare il
disequilibrio perché spesso è
allontanandomi da me stessa che capisco
quanto sia importante avere me stessa e
allontanandomi perdendo i miei valori
che è
proprio nella lontananza che capisco
l'importanza di averli fissi sempre con
me
Io non sono una ragazza così con una
vita così equilibrata perché ho
veramente tantissimi picchi sia di up
and down però cerco di andare
nella direzione
in cui voglio andare con la forza con
volontà
con costanza e con tenacia nonostante a
volte
anche io mi perda però perdersi è anche
una maniera di trovare il proprio
equilibrio
non ho tanto da aggiungere all'altro